hello and welcome to another episode of
not too deep i'm your host grace helbig
very excited to have comedian writer
thespian all around incredibly
thoughtful and curious person amanda
seals on today's episode we talk about
all of it honestly i'm still processing
uh all the beautiful advice and thoughts
that she has about her creative journey
the most wild story ever that i've heard
of someone doing stand-up for the first
time she tells me in this episode uh you
have to
listen to it to believe it to experience
it all of it i'm still processing uh we
also talk about her podcast small doses
which is also a book that she is uh
read through the audio version of too
get into all of it she is a busy
curious uh incredible human being and i
just truly had a really wonderful time
chatting with her about her artistic and
creative journey her thoughts on
entertainment media all of it um
especially her
thoughts on like being difficult you'll
hear all about it i'm getting a little
bit flooded in my thoughts of it so
please enjoy this episode of not too
deep with amanda seals
[Music]
amanda i'm so excited to talk to you i
feel like you are
what i have kind of gathered like you're
just professionally curious about
so many things that i find it so
interesting to kind of pick your brain
on all of this
i'm first curious about
how
do you describe
what it is that you do
to someone that might not know you i'm a
comedian yeah that's what you you go
okay
yeah
i mean everything i do
it's like i'm a comedian who can write
i'm a comedian who can act i'm a
comedian who can
produce um but at the end of the day
humor is the thread through everything i
do so
that's just the easiest and most like
succinct
way to sum it all up it's like the
skeleton key for yeah well i'm i wonder
how did comedy come into your world was
there like a moment that you realized
like this makes sense to me or was there
a person or a thing that happened for
you that just clicked
i mean i was always funny like that was
always just kind of like
in the mix of
the way that i thought about things and
the way i interact with the world yeah
um
but i was in the music business and i
have like independent albums and i was
hosting a lot of things
and
i remember around like 30ish on my
during my saturn returns
i was like
i was taking a turn i was taking it my
own turn because
i had been so immersed in music yeah for
like the past 10 years and i even had a
different name my name was amanda diva
yeah i mean that's what i'm so
fascinated by like the evolution of like
your artistic endeavors like you did
start in music and you started in like
hosting and looking word
yeah so how did that like how did you
start there first of all
so
it's funny because you said like was it
a person like when you when you were
naming like apostles and for me um music
it was literally one person i was i come
from a like musical family but one day i
was ushering
a show
at the suny purchase performing arts
center
and
my homeboy was like keeping me company
because like you can't watch the show so
you just have to like stand outside my
home always keep me company and we were
just talking we're just chit-chatting
talking and he was like have you ever
thought of rapping
and i was like i mean no he's like you
have a really good voice for rapping and
i was like
okay
and literally like
the next day maybe even that night i
like started writing raps as the fourth
member of the fuji's amazing and i still
have the right book with like all the
verses and everything
and but i couldn't rhyme on beat to save
my life i could not
rhyme on beat to save my life and so
i was like um
but i was but i but i did realize that
you know i
i've always been writing but i never
pursued i never considered myself a
writer right like when i was in school
like i was good at research paper it's
not like write poems or whatever but
yeah there were people i knew that were
like i am a writer and i was like i am
one who can move a pen yeah you know and
and so
i mean i even like wrote my whole my my
own book of monologues like freshman
year of high school but like but still
never small side activities yeah
literally though like never really put
together like oh like this is a
skill of yours and so when i started
writing the raps i was like oh i got i
can't rhyme on b but i can like
write like some witty really really
witty [ __ ] and then spoken word came
into the mix because
i went to
like we had like a talent show i was in
the conservatory at the time for theater
and they had like a talent show i don't
know why we're having a talent show when
we're here for theater but well you guys
have already gotten into the program
what else do you need to prove
so we do this talent show and my homeboy
in my class did a spoken word piece and
i didn't know that was an option like i
didn't i had never heard of the genre
yeah i didn't know that there was like
so i'm rapping but there's no beat
they say this is where i live and so i
started um getting on stage at school
and doing spoken word poems and then uh
that summer like of after my sophomore
year i was doing that in the city
and then i ended up on deaf poetry jam
on um hbo hold on one second hey hey hey
sit
sit
jordy so my dog just had
eye surgery
oh no
or good
he's not ashamed wow
the most vulnerable looking creature
incredible he's but he's up to mischief
right now so
like i get it but also like understand
like that's why i'm like sit
down
how did you guys come into each other's
lives
i rescued him he has one eye i rescued
him last i just him july 4th he's a
pandemic dog um
she had this other eye that just wasn't
functioning and though we got to take it
out yesterday and they were like
actually it wasn't an eye
it was like a cyst and the eye never
really grew
so
it's not like dramatic but it is
mysterious it's not
necessarily the normal situation
but
it gives character it adds complexity
and his name is jordy laffer after jody
laforge the starship enterprise who also
had vision impairment
so
there's the thing here um but no so to
answer your question i ended up i mean
i've had this kind of path of like
just
it's kind of a a perfect marriage of
like
freedom and fearlessness
i allow myself to kind of be free to go
with the flow if it's leading me in a
direction and then i have to exercise a
certain fear
for the possibility that i could be a
failure at it right so it's like
you know it felt right to go in this
spoken word direction and so i went but
i think the difference
i think the difference for a lot of
people is that i i don't go into it
thinking i don't want to fail i just go
into it thinking like this is something
i'm going to have to work at so
there's a humility in there yeah and
that humility saves you
from feeling the feeling of failure
because you're already going into it
like you know what i'm just going to
feel my way around i don't really know
you know this could be for me this could
not be for me we don't really know yeah
so you're kind you're grounded in just
exploring exploration and
you know this the commitment is not to
like necessarily being a star but
but just doing your best i mean i guess
it sounds cliche but so that's how i've
kind of approached everything and then
eventually
um you know i did the music thing for
like 10 years
uh and that was another thing where it
was like because i i take it you like
these coincidental like twists and turns
so i'll keep you but i mean
but you also talk about 10 years like
it's a drop in the pant like that's a
significant
amount of your because i'm sorry
but
also now it feels like in your
professional like artistic world like
that's wildly significant and then to be
able to kind of you know recognize what
you maybe liked or the voice that you
created in that universe and then to
like shift ebb and flow and move into
something new is fascinating
because i think it's like
i'm very honest about
where i'm at and where i want to go and
i think sometimes we're not as honest
with ourselves as we could be about that
and it hinders us from making like the
better decision right so yeah like there
was a certain point in music where i
just was like you're just never going to
be this like you're never going to get
to where you really think
where what you consider success you're
never going to get to because you're not
even going to give up enough of you to
get there
you know like i examined the music
business and was like yeah
[Applause]
you ain't built for this
but that takes a bit of like you know
the ability to zoom out and kind of like
see
grace you are so pretty do people tell
you this you are so
pretty back and she's louise your whole
instagram which i i love because it's uh
every other post is like you laying down
in repose but having this incredibly
profound thought about
like the way humans exist in the world
and a different way to enter into that
conversation and that's why i was like
uh this is gonna get deep because i feel
like you effortlessly
are curious about these things that
people kind of throw away but you're
able to bring comedy into it too that
makes it feel
more like relatable or understandable in
some way and because you've done like
music and you've done hosting and you've
done acting and you you do comedy
through all of it i'm always curious for
people that you know play other people
but also exist as themselves behind the
scenes like
what if there's one avenue maybe that
you enjoy more or
how you approach each one if you do it
differently at all or if you're always
bringing your
self into all of it
well it's funny i was in the
conservatory of acting at suny purchase
and then a jackass uh lied to a
professor to get me kicked out and so
yeah that's like a living podcast
and
um and so i ended up appealing the
decision and was able to just take a
year off but then i decided to just quit
the conspiracy all together and and
created my own major and finished
college under my own major but i bring
that up because
i remember
sitting
uh with my knees to my chest leaned up
against the studio of our acting class
crying about the fact that i was like
being kicked out of this program and
then there was a little birdie in the
back of my head that was like did you
really want to spend the next year of
your life
doing check off
now you know you didn't really want to
do that
you know you would much prefer to say
your own words and perform in your own
space so you can cry now but this is the
best decision yeah and it was like just
this little voice in the back but it was
just like i know you're upset but i'm
gonna get louder eventually yeah and
and so that was an interesting turning
point though because up until that point
i had been very much like i'm an actor
but in that little boy speaking to me i
realized like you're someone who acts
like you like
the joy that other people get from
playing other roles you don't
get yeah your joy comes from saying your
own words and that's a different thing
and that's very yeah that's beautiful to
recognize but also really difficult
especially when you're surrounded i'm
sure at that point by all these other
actors that were just like
finding their calling and their purpose
in this thing and then you're like
i there's something i'm resisting about
this what is this and how can i trust
that voice
it's so true and i mean that whole year
of me trying to
figure out what i was going to do if i'm
going to stay at school if i'm going to
go back to the conservatory am i going
to quit school and just like i mean i
had this big pipe dream you know i'm
going to quit school and i'm just going
to get a job in the city and i would go
to utah again
me while my mom is in orlando like oh my
god what's happening
and um
but you know but but in hindsight there
was always a plan at work you know i'm
saying like even though the plan pivots
and i think that's the overall kind of
if i like look at the course of my
artistic journey there's always a plan
it's just there's always a willing to
pivot there's always a willingness to
pivot like i never i never feel
like i have to be
married to the plan it's not to say that
i'm a quitter but i never feel like
i guess
on a basic notice best idea wins yeah so
if i'm on this if i'm on this trajectory
and there's a better idea it's like
let's switch project trajectory yeah i
mean the idea and trust it and pivoting
i think is
pivotal for lack of a better word that
it's
truly especially when you wear so many
artistic hats that like you have to be
able to recognize at what moment you
should go down what avenue and that's
hard for people i think that feel like
they have to choose a lane and stay in
it
well you know
and then as you continue to to like
expand as a multi-hyphenate right like
yeah you lose kind of the option of just
doing one thing at a time yeah and so
you have to become a lot more ardent
about
like really creating synergy with things
or else you'll lose your minds like i
know like right now
i need to be writing like i'm at a phase
in my life where like i need to be
writing i have all these ideas that have
been percolating here and now i have
enough like business knowledge and savvy
etc to be able to take the ideas put
them on paper and like put them into the
marketplace right mm-hmm so
but at the same time i'm a stand-up yeah
i do smart funny and black lives i have
employees i
am an actor i'm gonna be like i have all
these other things and i have a mortgage
you're spending lots of plates at the
same time i'm curious about your
artistic process if you have one that
you
utilize over and over or if it's
different for each project that you're
working on like in terms of writing do
you have like rituals do you sit down do
you have a sacred space like do you do
do you like what works for you
um well one thing i just want to say
before i even answer that was because
your original question was like how did
i find my way
to call in comedy like the overhead yeah
and
in like
when i turned like 31
i realized like i don't want to do music
anymore what do i want to do like how
like what am i doing
and
everyone kept telling me like
you got to be the it girl and you got to
like stop you can't keep talking about
social justice and black things and you
got to like get the you gotta get the
white girl so like you gotta get the
gaze like you like every like it was
like very like
methodical and formulaic that people
were saying
and
what i ended up doing on a basic note
was i just looked at people whose
careers i'm admired even if i didn't
necessarily like like i'm not i wouldn't
consider myself like a chelsea handler
fan but i'm a fan of like what she has
managed to do with her voice yeah right
and i looked at her ellen and chris rock
and i was like you know what they all
what they all have in common is they
have built
multimedia moguldoms
based on their point of view
but there was one thing that they all
did that i didn't do at the time and it
was stand-up
and i was like that's what you're
missing
wow
because
without doing stand up you're just
humorous
what a sentence
that is
very true and also it was like you were
in your own escape room and you figured
the key to get yourself out of it
and like literally it was like a boom
like oh
you need to not only do stand up you
need to be good at it like it can't just
be some like dalliance you need to be
good at it and it wasn't like i like the
next day was like
new york city i'm here like like take me
to the stage yeah but it was like i just
kind of put it out in the open then a
few months later out the blue when snl
was looking for their [ __ ] when they
were like we don't we need we don't have
one we need one um all these like
showcases popped up and this girl just
hit me out the blue sent me an email was
like hey um we're doing a showcase we'd
love to have you headline i've never
done stand-up before but she saw me on
vh1
on best week ever with all these other
standards yes i'm on there with nick
crowell and mullaney and you know
gerard small and all these stand-ups
that are like legit stand-ups so just by
the nature of association she was like
you must be a santa too and i was like i
would love to do it i can't headline
but the people that i was on the show
with i was lit sasha's amateur who ended
up getting before snell was on the show
it was like sashir marina franklin naomi
perrigan like i mean my first stand-up
show was amongst a incredible lineup of
black women comedians yeah and um
i didn't bomb that's incred i mean the
amount of pressure trajectory yeah i
mean to really throw you into an
atmosphere where it's like sink or swim
holy [ __ ]
and on the way there i was switching to
the l train from my new yorkers i was
switching to the electronic 14th and
someone had jumped in front of the train
and in true new york fashion everyone
was like come on
oh god
tonight and it was november 6 2013
and halloween had just finished and i'm
standing on the curb and this marco
walks up and was like do you want to
share a [ __ ] cab and i was like tote
and so she was like straight out of
girls and so we get in the cab and we go
to williamsburg and
on the way we start talking about
halloween and it was a year where just
an incredibly high number of blackface
incidents had taken place
and
i was talking about it she was like
what's blackface
and so but she wasn't like she was
genuinely just ignorant to nothing okay
okay and so i was like telling her and
she was like that's [ __ ] up
that was like
yes
yes it is
and i got to the show
and grace
everything i prepared out the window my
whole set was about that camera right
how and that's
that's how i do stand up to this day
i don't write i don't write my jokes
no everything's on stage so if i i craft
on stage i never sit down and write it
wow i mean that's
impressive and also
such a
monumentous night in so many ways my god
so but i just say that like that's kind
of the
the part so when you talk about process
yeah
that um
i'm really good at listening to myself i
was gonna say it seems like you trust
your instincts that you have a very good
internal dialogue with yourself or a
very like
succinct one to be able to trust
from what it sounds like even from back
when you were in the conservatory like
this voice whoever it is whatever it is
kind of guiding you in a direction
i mean process is so different for
everybody and you know
writing is hard yeah like
because it's so completely
it requires such focus yeah but then
that focus is also just like i'm tired
of focusing
well especially because we are now like
unconsciously conditioned by all these
devices and all these distractions all
the time that you have to like
de-program yourself to be able to focus
solely on one thing which is what
writing commands and demands is like
this linear single focus which is so
much easier said than done
you really think when you when you're
not writing you're like why can't it's
less than doubt
focus
it's gonna go down and then you sit down
you're like
i wonder
i forgot to finish watching that surfing
documentary yeah exactly
they had just gotten to portugal i need
to see how this ends you know like
so that's been
in terms of process i'm establishing a
process in terms of writing scripts
because i'm in that
it's a new space yeah for me um when i
wrote my book small doses i thought it
would take me two weeks it took me two
it took me a year
it's okay i don't know but i had no idea
i i mean i don't know why i thought it
would take me two weeks i was like you
wrote you wrote research papers in a day
no biggie well okay let me put a pin in
that for one second so we can take a
break and then come back because i want
to talk about small doses uh the the
podcast and the audiobook and all of it
i'm really fascinated about your whole
process with it so we'll be right back
with more not too deep
[Music]
hello listeners grace helbig here
wanting to say two things a big thank
you for listening to the podcast uh if
you're a regular listener if this is
your first time listening welcome and
thank you
and uh second thing if you are enjoying
yourself here in this not too deep world
we've built and you'd like to leave us a
review that would be so wonderful if you
can go to the itunes store the app store
and leave us a lovely little review
comment how are you feeling good bad
otherwise maybe just good or otherwise
would be appreciated other than that
enjoy the podcast
okay amanda let's talk small doses tell
me how this first came about for you and
the evolution of it for you
so small doses is my podcast and i
started my podcast at the top of the
year 2018.
and it it evolved as like a self-help
from the hips that's basically the brand
and we've given it in the sense that
you as you've mentioned like i'm very
curious about like how
our mind works how social norms work you
know what civility really is and just
kind of the interactions of of humans
and whatnot and so
um
and just our processes in humanity right
like how we identify our identities like
how we uh
carve out our boundaries how we make our
spaces like just the human process is
like
it's it's i'm very curious yeah about it
i mean it's endlessly fascinating
because it's constantly evolving
yes
and so i talk about it a lot of times
and at the end of the day the bottom
line becomes like in the midst of the
constant evolution and the
willy-nilliness of it all how do you
remain healthy like mentally healthy
yeah so that that's what small doses at
its core is about and of course like by
nature of me just being a funny person
it has a humorous
tone to it and we have guests and
after doing it for a year people
and i was also like talking in the same
spaces on my instagram people were like
you know i'd really like
to have this like in writing because a
lot of times like i want to refer back
to something you've said and i just like
can't find it in your podcast et cetera
et cetera so that started me on the
journey to writing the book
and i took a
very uh
what's the word i'm looking for i took a
very
i don't know why i can't think of the
word but
i just
i i did not take an orthodox approach to
this book and it was by no means basic
yeah like
i was like i'm gonna write essays i'm
gonna write stories i'm gonna write
blurbs i'm gonna write poems and
um
it
really is a beautiful book by nature of
the fact that we also put my drawings in
it oh cool um
so it's like a very you know i really
love my my editor samantha weiner at um
abrams because she really just
understood me yeah and everybody else we
had pitched this to was like could you
just do a book of essays and it's like
well that's kind of what everyone does
yeah and it's not that there's anything
wrong with that but it was like i would
like to do something a little bit more
unique because i'm like a weird bird
yeah but it's also it makes it that much
more intimate into you it's like more of
a fully formed kind of like brainscape
of you versus like when you talk about
something it's very one lane of a person
and thoughts and this seems like you get
to cover a lot of bases i do
i do and i i really get a lot of joy
from doing that like i've had a lot of
people pitch me doing
shows and they're like you know um we'd
love to have you host a politics show
you know we'd love to have you hope it's
a relationship show or whatever and i'm
just like
that sounds so
boring
yeah
and
i
in that curiosity like i like to talk
about a number of things and so small
doses
you know we have a chapter on womanhood
we have a chapter on race we have a
chapter on people are weird you know we
have a chapter on careers um so you know
i get to touch on these different things
that have really been a part of my
experience and eventually i'll write a
part two um
but it was
a really daunting task because i had
written out this table of contents and
then was like you know you gotta
actually write it these are the
headlines you need the articles now yeah
yeah
and it took it took
i learned that my process in writing in
that
respect
i need
to carve out like very specific times
where that's all i'm doing and then time
when i'm not doing it at all
that's the balance yeah so i need like a
week where i'm not doing anything but
this yeah yeah yeah
but then i need two weeks of not having
to think about this i'm doing everything
but this like there's hella typos in the
first run of the book because
i had to edit it like i i was like i
don't want to [ __ ] read this i just
wrote it
i know to go back i mean yeah what's
your relationship with going back and
looking at your own work do you have a
like uh
is that something you probably enjoy
doing i like it yeah i do but like i
read slow whether i wrote it or not same
song
you know and i mean i had to like and i
was on tour at the time and i had this
giant manuscript and i have to be like
on flights with this giant manuscript
like on like
the three day trade table down and then
it's like
and then you know then the person's like
oh boy this is your book and now we're
not i'm not editing yeah i'm talking
about the book yeah yeah yeah
so you know it was it so process
so something that's interesting about
process
so i was telling you that as a stand-up
like i don't
write on i don't write
jokes on paper so yeah you know people
keep asking me like oh like when are you
gonna do another special when you get
another special i'm like well i'm not on
stage like it's been a pandemic and i
just haven't
you know for stand up you kind of got to
be in like a stand-up mode you know and
i just haven't been in stand-up mode so
i don't have i mean i can pull up i can
pull two hours out my ass any time but
for a special
it should be special exactly
i'm like you know i don't have it right
now but when i was hosting the bet
awards in 2020
we were in a pandemic yeah
and so we couldn't do
the awards live right so i had to do
them in my house
which is
i'm sure uh just a really easy and fun
experience
listen it was
ah madness and
it's a huge layer of trust that what
you're writing and the jokes that you're
saying because you have no ability to
bounce it off of alive anything
that you really have to believe in what
you're saying and what you're doing
so i have written five one-woman shows
wow
and
what i realized because i was trying to
write my monologue yeah opening
monologue and like it wasn't coming yeah
because i don't write jokes so here i am
trying to like this sounds funny and
it's like
no it's not and so
i caught myself and i was like you know
what
you need to write this as a one-woman
show not write it as
a standout interesting because when
you're writing when i'm writing in a
one-woman show space i'm writing for
myself yeah yeah because the audience
isn't there
expecting
free like there's a different exchange
between a comic
and their audience and a
uh thespian and their audience and even
if there is no fourth wall even if it's
one woman show space and you're speaking
directly to them
they haven't come there with the
expectation that you're going to tell
jokes
yeah yeah yeah now they may have come
with the expectation that they're going
to laugh
but they haven't come there with the
expectation that they're going to have
to validate your comedy
and so it's a different mindset of how
you write because for me at least
because i'm writing from the point of
performance versus from the point of
setup punch yeah yeah set up punch and
i'm not even [ __ ] you
at the end of the day when you look at
the monologue it's like oh here's set up
punch but by just changing my mind state
i was able to write it without needing
that yeah
and i was and i wrote it in 20 minutes
incredible once i had that epiphany i
wrote it in 20 minutes wow yeah just
reframing what the assignment is for
yourself gives you clarity that's so
interesting
um
okay
i'm gonna move on to the two questions i
ask every single guest that is with me
on the podcast um the first is who alive
or dead would you most like to throw
cold spaghetti at
um i would
i would like to throw cold spaghetti
i mean honestly i'm trying to narrow it
down yeah i mean and this is a
it's an answer that i recognize will
change constantly it's just who in this
moment comes
i would like to throw cold spaghetti at
the supreme court
very much
because i'm just like
[ __ ] are you guys
what are we
my god
um
okay we don't have to go too deeply into
that uh the other question that every
single guest on the podcast is to tell
us your worst pant [ __ ] story or
like a bathroom emergency situation
but you can only use three words or like
small phrases to describe the event so
for example mine is college jogging
front lawn
[Music]
mcdonald's bathroom oh [ __ ]
okay
release
okay
cbs receipt wow
wow
thank god some of those receipts are so
[ __ ] long and
that you throw them in bags because you
never know when you're gonna need one
didn't know i'd need it
keep your receipts
for uh your taxes and for bathroom
emergencies either keep the receipts or
check first
that there
is toilet paper present
very true
[Music]
okay now we have a section of the
podcast called deep and hot where i have
a deep question that we have prepared
for you um and then also i'm curious
about your hot take on kind of like a
subject or thing that we have prepared
for you so
deep question for you
have you felt pressure to numb your
intelligence
to numb my intelligence
in the
i i felt pressure for myself really
because
yeah because um
you know james baldwin has a phrase that
i'm paraphrasing where he basically says
to be black and aware in america is to
live in a constant state of rage
and
i'm very black and aware in america and
rage is
tiring it is exhausting and for all
intents and purposes it's
it becomes a moot point because it
doesn't necessarily have any
effect in the way that you want to see
change change is very very slow and
ranges rage is very very fast it's
and it's deep in its heart um so i feel
like you know
i've
i've felt pressure at times to
um
just be ignorantly blissful
for my own sanity
and
it and then you have to
balance that with the reality of like
if you
don't
allow yourself to know about things and
you don't allow yourself to care about
them and you don't allow yourself to be
a part of changing them then you're
really nihilistic
and you should either
just off yourself now
um
because you're like taking up air in
space yeah or
you know you're just kind of associated
you're a sociopath at that point
and i'm not interested in either of
those things
yeah so this is for this is really cheap
yeah
we've been doing the podcast for seven
years we can only we've been in the
shallow end for so long it's uh i'm sick
of it
no it's a doozy man and it's like you
really
like even on instagram like i've had to
mute certain accounts not because i
don't like them but because it was just
like i just i can't take it i can't take
a police brutality story today yeah
yeah
and it's hard to be creative yeah some
people thrive some people are their best
creative selves in the midst of strife
struggling chaos yeah um i can't say
that that's the case for myself i am i
am not a mary j blige in that regard
yeah yeah
interesting
it is yeah finding what works for you or
what makes the most sense to preserve
certain areas of your emotional
well-being and your intellect um
and that's like what are you here for
yeah so it's like if it's impeding upon
you doing what you're here for yeah yeah
yeah
it's i mean it's a dance it's a
correlation yeah it seems like it's a
constant consideration
um which is in of itself very exhausting
too
with that though okay hot take you
posted this video that i was like i
thought so fascinating um just your hot
take on being difficult because i knew
it yeah i i i thought it was for people
that haven't seen it can you kind of
like elaborate on what you posted
because i was like this is a really
interesting way to talk about this
so i have throughout my life been
labeled difficult and like went to
therapy for the sole purpose of
understanding like why am i why do
people keep saying i'm difficult why do
people not like me wow and my therapist
was like you know we're gonna get to the
bottom of
what are the ways that you're
um
in your own way
making things difficult and then what
are the ways
that people are
projecting their [ __ ] onto you yeah and
calling you difficult yeah
and so like we spent years
you know literally we spent years really
like getting to the bottom of like what
are the things that i
like about myself that other people
don't like
you know like i'm a very meticulous
person i'm very driven i'm type a i'm
um
i'm literal
yeah so
if you tell me something
i i believe it
you know and i will hold you to it right
well you said
did it at the end of that yeah and then
you know so and i'm
i'm um
i'm very honest and and understand at a
certain point in my life i feel like i
was honest to a fault
um i think people love to say like
honesty is the best policy and it's like
correct however policies are written um
different ways for different purposes
you don't always have to deliver it in a
fashion that undermines the purpose of
sharing it and sometimes like i know
that i just didn't understand that
science right sure so
i say all that to say that i did this
video where i was like you know people
call me difficult and they're right
uh i'm paraphrasing i'm difficult to
[ __ ] over i'm difficult to be misled i'm
difficult to
lie to um you know and
if you are
someone that is trying to do any of
these things uh and i'm gonna make it
difficult for you to do that
but it's there's something about you
like it because it seems like through
your life you pr you process things like
um openly like you very much are
like there's a beautiful vulnerability
like you say you don't write your jokes
that you get on stage and you kind of
like work through stuff and the same
seems to be that like people i think get
on guard when someone is so
like you know vulnerable in that sense
and like outspoken or for lack of a
better word that because
there's no assumptions
in that way no
ulterior there's no
subtext yeah
so the arrow is coming straight
at you
and some people and the beauty is
finding out that some people love that
[ __ ] yeah
that's the beauty because you get
tricked into thinking that because
a lot of people don't like that yeah
that that's the way it should be yeah
correct and it's it's really not the
case i mean i think we live in a very
passive aggressive society yeah um
we live in a very narcissistic society
oh yeah so like if you exist in that
space like you are very unnerving to a
lot of people's way of existing and
um and when you are unnerving to
people's way of existing they will make
effort
to [ __ ] with your way of existing yeah
projections pure projection
that's it yeah so you know it's but but
what was beautiful about that video was
how many people identified with it and
what was hilarious was how many men were
like and that's why you're gonna stay
single and i'm like
jesus like shut up
i'm also not but also like it's just
like this is not that's not the goal
it's good to know that they're busy
enough to carve out some time to post
that on your video that they seem booked
and busy and doing well
so but the the idea of the difficult
thing is also because i feel like women
we put this on each other too it's not
just some patriarchal thing patriarchy
has
the same way white supremacy has
brainwashed black people patriarchy has
bran some black people patriarchy has
brainwashed some women like it and and
into being our own enemies right
and
i
have definitely had just experiences
with women
who are calling me difficult for simply
doing the thing or saying the thing that
they
would like themselves to have the
courage to do that they've thought like
it's not like what you're saying is a
completely foreign
you know idea concept yeah
and i mean there are other times where
i've been difficult
so there's that
there are other times where i'm just
like
i wanted lemonade but you're the
self-awareness to a fault is critical
and i think there's also this is [ __ ]
[ __ ] that people act like you can't
everyone has difficulty at some point
like everyone is obstinate at some point
you know like it's rare to meet the
person who's just the person who's just
like yeah man we just go with the
flowman yeah i'm saying man it's like
they're probably also high as [ __ ] you
know and like there's enough i also
don't smoke or drink so i'm always
dealing with this world
in a sober state of mind yeah which is
that yeah people that can't deal with it
numb themselves in different ways so
when someone is so
sober in their thoughts viewpoints and
opinions about it it can be very
confronting for people
it's comforting for me
i live with this every day all day long
so well it's go ahead well i was going
to move into because we're towards the
end now but i want to know like what's
next for you what's on the horizon
what's coming up
i am on a mission race
um i have been on insecure on hbo for
the past six for the past five seasons
for the past six years yeah and it the
final episode is what december 26th i
think
yes it is coming
wow um
and for those who don't know like in
this business a lot of times when you're
on a show and you're at a certain level
your character is a certain level like
you can't do other work yeah true yeah
because you're under contract to that
project
um
and
i will also say like when i when i since
moving here to la like it's been a
learning curve and just a learning
process of understanding like what my
value
in this business is and what the value
of this business is to me yeah um
and
i have finally kind of not kind of i
have finally reached a place of clarity
about what i want what i want to do with
it and where i want to go with it and so
my i am on mission operation undeniable
and
i have dedicated myself for the next
year
to being as prolific as possible in the
effort of
really showing
the world to myself the undeniability of
my talent because
[Music]
i really genuinely feel like i have
creative work to share on a bigger
platform that can really be
um
they can just really be as like
moving is not the word but that helpful
or helpful yeah that can be
impactful important yeah
that can be impactful in
in a time where i feel like we are
rapidly descending towards mayhem yeah
like i just think that it is imperative
that
voices like mine
um
are
given space because the voices that are
getting platforms right now
by and large are
dangerous yeah and there has to be a
counter culture
that's i mean that sounds beautiful and
also a big old task for yourself but
also how can you not like if you're
called to do this how can you possibly
ignore the call
it would you know what though i gotta
tell you since i
kind of like
decided that
it's like that book the alchemist man
like once you
decide what you want the universe
conspires to give it to you that's
awesome so there have been there's just
been like abundance in terms of like
support and interest and spaces opening
up like
right before my eyes um
and
i think there's
just a
um
an excitement that i have that i haven't
had in a while this pandemic this panini
has been i mean and it could have gone a
different way you know to come out of it
feeling so like rejuvenated and excited
and it you know it did yeah a different
way i had a whole depression
yeah i had a pregnancy i had a pregnancy
i had a miscarriage i had a depression i
had a whole set of [ __ ]
that i had to like you know navigate my
way through yeah and then um
luckily to your point like when i got to
the other side of that there was this
clarity that said like
because i was like i'm gonna quit i'm
done with this i hate everybody here
yeah i hate everybody here i'm gonna eat
lunch in the library from now on
it's just over it
and um my dude was like
are you sure um and i was like yes guess
i'm sure i'm absolutely sure how dare
you yeah and
but he was like i just feel like
you've worked
so hard to get to like this point
that it would just
[Music]
be a disservice to yourself
to just bow out
and that's a good person that's a good
person that can see all of you
yeah he could see it and i was just like
i mean whatever like you don't know me
but i desperately want to hear all of
this because you do know me
and so for all intents and purposes i
figured it out and i just i'm and and
you know we started this podcast with
you talking about like my curiosity and
i think i'm just always trying to
figure out like what is the next
space of like
happiness and
elevation that i can like
like shimmy into yeah i you know you got
a body wave through the [ __ ]
and
you know i always i try like i'll be
like like a series of wackness will
happen and then i'll be like ah
you're in the midst of two weeks of
wackness and it's like my body like my
mind just decides you've got one more
week of wackness and that's it and then
you will come to the other side but that
is yeah these like death rebirth cycles
that happen like creatively spiritually
all of it are
to be able to hold that recognition of
like this is not permanent this is
temporary and that there is the reason
this is so bad is because good has to
happen to be able to understand things
getting bad um
that's beautiful i hope you write more
self-help books in some capacity because
i feel like i learned a fuckton
um thank you of course uh before we wrap
up completely we like to give a little
token of our appreciation for um being a
guest and that is a personalized
horoscope from us to you that melissa
will play in the chat uh when she does
if you could read it out loud to the
class i think we got your birthday
correct
dear cancer
crab of the stars
mars and scopio forms a sextile with
pluto and capricorn earlier this week
provided the perfect opportunity for a
romantic date if you missed it
well [ __ ] maybe next year there we go i
actually did go on a date this week well
there you go it's in the stars they
predicted it was in the goddamn stars
the stars predicted it and i am tapped
in hell yeah and thus
um amanda where can people find
everything that you're up to if they
don't know the podcast the book all of
it
uh follow me on instagram and twitter
amanda seals you can go to smart funny
and black dot com and that's where our
that's basically our source hub for
everything you can subscribe to our
patreon which is patreon.com backslash
smart funny and black and you can listen
to my podcast small doses wherever pods
are casted and small doses the book is
available now in paperback yeah and you
read the audiobook right oh yes and
there's thank you grace there's an
audible as well there's an audio book
that i read um and by the way i had
throat surgery last year on my vocal
cords so when you hear the audio book i
sound like
i
it's a it's a character it's your
reading character yeah it's not
figure it out i love that so but thank
you guys so much this has been fantastic
thank you amanda go get into everything
that she's up to and also get ready for
the future because you got big plans i
can't wait i'm so excited this is so
lovely thank you so much for your time
super appreciate it and we'll see you
guys next time on another episode of not
too deep goodbye
too deep too deep too deep deep not too
deep with christ
not too deep is a production of grace
helbig incorporated producer melissa d
montz edited by shireen laniunis
post-production sound by chris henry and
an extra special thanks to flula for the
theme music